let it down okay no okay write it okay
hi team Coco we're circulation Liverpool
and these are our favorite YouTube
videos my favourite video is baby monkey
going backwards on a pig I just think
you know it's really shows sort of how
far we've come as humans over time and
you know it's just a great comedy piece
of a monkey and a pig
[Music]
[Music]
hello I'm Joe my favorite YouTube video
is a series it's called the old hockey
hair team 2012 was a fantastic year
every year when Minnesota the high
school state hockey championships
some genius collects all the best hair
styles into a compilation video at
number eight we have a little combo
platter when's the last time you saw two
people right next to each other in line
with that type of salad if you did it
for the last four years and every year I
wait with bated breath and there's some
great salad at number six from Duluth
East we have a look that's kind of hard
to describe kind of part shower cap a
little bit of fro but still hockey here
hi I'm Colin and my favorite youtube
video is Terry Crews muscle music where
he has sensors on each of his muscles
and it gets more ridiculous hi I'm Sam
my favorite YouTube video is sporty by
Kyle it's probably one of the weirdest
things I've ever seen score per one
score what touch to score more points or
win the game Banjos is over there making
the worst calls Ben Jules yeah you just
have to sit it's just not just tell me
that to the team names of the sport I'm
just trying to figure out I don't know
what is sick come on Ben Jules get loose
thank you for watching there are
favorite YouTube videos I felt like I
should do something